دوا صوتها في سماء الغناء البريطاني ونجحت
في حجز مكانه بين النجمات الاكثر شهره في
العالم
فنافست تايلور سويفت
وغيرهما كما اصبحت وجها لحملات اعلاميه
وانسانيه على مستوى بلادها والعالم انها
دوليبا صاحبه الاغنيات الاكثر رواجا خلال
الاعوام القليله الماضيه فما قصتها
ولدت دواء عام
1995 لعائله البانيه لاجئه في لندن كان
والدها
عازف جيتار ما شجعها لتبدا الغناء وهي في
الخامسه قبل ان تلتحق بمدرسه سلفيا يونغ
المسرحيه لتتابع الدروس في النهار وتعمل
في الليل بوظيفه نادله الى ان انتقلت مع
عائلتها الى كوسوفو وهي الخطوه التي لم
تدم طويلا حيث عادت الى لندن بمفردها
لتواصل مسيرتها الغنائيه في لندن شعرت
الفتاه الطموحه بانها ضائعه ووحيده بمدينه
كبيره وهناك عملت في عروض الازياء ومع ذلك
لم تحصل على الكثير من العروض لانها لم
تكن مهتمه بفقدان الوزن
بعد ثلاث سنوات من التنقل بالوظائف
العشوائيه في لندن وفيما كانت ليبا تنشر
اغلفه اغانيها المفضله على حساب خاص في
يوتيوب وقعت عقدا احترافيا مع شركه ورنر
برادرز لانتاج البومها الاول في عام 2015
اصدرت اغنيتين منفردتين نيولاف وبذوان وهي
الاغنيه التي حققت نجاحا في اوروبا وحازت
المركز الاول في بلجيكا وبولندا
في عام 2016
ظهر اسم ليبا في قائمه اذاعه بي بي سي
لافضل الاصوات فيما كانت تقوم بجولتها
الاولى في المملكه المتحده واوروبا
في عام 2017 اصدرت البومها الاول الذي حمل
اسمها وكان لديها اربع اغنيات منفرده كان
اهمها نيوروز التي حلت بالمركز الاول في
المملكه المتحده وكانت الاكثر مبيعا حتى
الان في العام 2018
تعرضت ليبا لانتكاسه في حياتها العائليه
حيث انفصلت عن زوجها الفنان بولك لاين
الذي اقترنت به في عام 2017 كما تعرضت
لحمله اعلاميه ضدها ولكنها تجاوزت ذلك
وحققت المزيد من النجاح مع البومها
واطلقت اول اغنيه فيديو كليب لها وهي
اغنيه وي ار جود حتى اليوم لدى ليبا اكثر
من 30 اغنيه فرديه والعديد من الاعمال
الفنيه التي اهلتها لنيل جوائز فنيه مهمه
ولعده مرات مثل جائزه غرامي
وجائزه
كما تتصدر قائمه
لعام 2022 وفي رصيدها ثروه تقدر بنحو خمسه
وثلاثين مليون دولار بعد ان كانت تعمل
نادله في مطعم
[موسيقى]